are you ready for more Resident Evil 7  goodness I'm Tony this is a GameSpot  news update and to keep up with all the  latest video game DLC be sure to  subscribe  oh and be warned there are some spoilers  in this one if you've played through  Resident Evil 7 you know a certain  recurring character shows up at the end  that's Chris Redfield and he's getting  his own playable chapter called not a  hero that title says a lot considering  chris is shown to be working for the  evil umbrella corporation at the end of  the main game we'll find out what's  going on sometime this spring but for  now Capcom has released a few  screenshots not a hero will be totally  free and it's coming to ps4 Xbox one and  PC if you want more Resident Evil  coverage in the meantime tune in to  GameSpot this Sunday at 3 p.m. Pacific  for the premiere of reboot our newest  show that digs deeper into games and the  culture around them and for all the  latest gaming news you're already in the  right place